you know it would have been dope
what do you guys think uh
was the strategic error in the versus
performance
who's path i mean on dip sets behalf
because obviously the locks won
just says from a hip-hop fan perspective
chemistry chemistry
i would say like preparation and um
you know the right records and um
you know just really studying
your opponent because they didn't really
i don't think they took it you know they
getting paid for it like they can i'm
pretty sure they get a nice bag for it
you get what i'm saying so
yeah i think the money kind of created a
cushion
and it's like some some people are
coming into it's verses so versus was
always the thing where you're celebrated
you know what i mean and it's not more
like a battle this this is more like
it's new york
it's the garden at the at the garden
that's the garden
you get what i'm saying and you know
yeah
yeah i think preparation is what because
i felt like if cam would have had some
pick some different records as far as
like even freestyle mm-hmm what come on
yeah i don't feel like he did dug in his
bag like he could have yeah
stupid the catalog is stupid the mixtape
mixtapes i could have jumped up there
and told them like do this like yo do
this this this
what what do you what would you have
like what do you think he didn't perform
that you would have had them perform
shake
um nah not even just recognized i think
so fast
freestyle [ __ ] damn like
cam like uh like even his verse on ben
from tv mm-hmm yeah that's what's crazy
is they did that and i was like
part two verse
and got everybody out of there he could
have did that's me like and kiss that in
the interview he was like
certain
play so i don't really feel like you
know i don't know
so to answer your question kev i feel
like um like best out would have been
like a dope song and the irony is um we
you know we walked the fighter out to
that record you know before he and he
won you know i'm saying so and the irony
of that also being best out is the same
record from um the fight night game
people that used to play back in the day
so you know
i guess that's starting to be like the
the symbolic record of fighters now you
know what i'm saying like if you don't
come out the best style you're gonna get
something good there is some irony that
no matter what you guys did end up
performing in the building the same
night how ironic right that [ __ ] is kind
of wild to think about but there was a
fight prior it's gone you guys it's gone
and we was raised i mean i went
backstage and all that i went to the
dip set like uh dresser room yeah he
went backstage uh yeah shout out to
everybody that's behind the scenes we
you know we um you know deb said in
everybody but we we we
began as a family so we know everybody
from you know the the guys from drive
the truck to the the guys that hold
people down yeah they're all family so